bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode de 248 ce
soir mon invité est le premier
secretaire délégué du Parti socialiste
et maire de Rouen Nicolas Mayer
rossignol
S
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
la semaine dernière vous essayez donc à
Montpellier chez votre homologue Mickaël
Delafosse pour le coloc de refondation
votre courant interne au parti
socialiste la presse parle de courant
anti-ups et anti-mélonchon est-ce que
vous validez ces termes non parce qu'on
n'est pas anti c'est pas c'est pas le
sujet nous le rassemblement de la gauche
je vais vous dire on est on est croyant
et pratiquant moi je suis maire de Rouen
et je m'occupe aussi de l'agglomération
roanaise il y a toute la gauche dedans y
compris d'ailleurs des partisans de LFI
donc c'est pas c'est pas le sujet par
contre on pense que aujourd'hui la
gauche elle est faible elle est à moins
de 30% elle est dans un périmètre trop
étroit il y a des beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans
l'offre de gauche actuelle et elle est
déséquilibrée en termes de respect et
d'équilibre des différents des
différentes formations de gauche donc il
y a tout à fait en réalité et il y a
urgence parce que sinon c'est le
rassemblement national qui va gagner
alors vous avez créé refondation c'est
quoi le but à présent de ce mouvement de
ce courant quels sont les principales
idées que vous souhaitez donc
pour pour la France en fait ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
Françaises et de français aujourd'hui
qui qui se sentent orphelins c'est à
dire qu'il attendent une offre de gauche
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans le
paysage parce que on voit bien que le
monde est insoutenable du point de vue
de l'épuisement des ressources
naturelles du point de vue des
inégalités sociales qui a un nouveau
modèle qui a inventé alors c'est
toujours difficile dans ces cas-là parce
qu'on sait pas par où commencer nous on
pense que la gauche a un rôle important
à jouer et qu'il faut donc des
refondations de cette gauche et
effectivement vous avez raison il faut
commencer par les valeurs les
convictions et puis les idées les
projets par exemple je vais donner
quelques exemples très concrets
aujourd'hui on voit bien que sur la
question de l'écologie souvent quand on
prend des mesures ça peut apparaître
comme négatif sur le plan social si on
si je vous interdis de prendre votre
voiture sous prétexte qu'elle est trop
ancienne ce qu'on appelle les aides les
zones affaiblissement vous allez me dire
tu es gentil mais moi ma voiture je l'ai
payé je peux j'ai pas les moyens d'en
payer une autre comment je fais etc etc
donc comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour faire en sorte que quand on vous
demande de changer de voiture pour de
bonnes raisons livraison écologique ou
de santé ou d'environnement et bien vous
n'ayez rien à payer en tout cas rien à
avancer vous voyez ce genre de choses
autre exemple sur l'Europe bon bah
l'Europe c'est à la fois évidemment une
solution un grand espoir et puis pour
beaucoup de gens c'est vécu comme un
problème l'Europe parce que on a
l'impression qu'elle nous impose des
règles des contraintes etc alors qu'en
réalité l'Europe c'est notre avenir
évidemment parce que c'est à cette
échelle là qu'on peut régler plein de
problèmes donc il faut que les nouvelles
générations elles soient de plus en plus
européenne nous on propose
Erasmus pour tous pour que tous les
jeunes des nouvelles générations
puissent passer au moins 6 mois dans un
autre pays l'Union européenne voyez bon
c'est quelques exemples je pourrais vous
donner d'autres exemples la culture les
transports gratuits ça c'est très
important c'est je cite ça parce que
Michael fait ça à Montpellier nous on
développe ça aussi à Rouen voilà c'est
des exemples précis pour refonder la
gauche en partant d'abord des idées
parce que sinon plus personne ne sait ce
que pense les socialistes c'est quand
même dommage alors que franchement il y
a des idées qui ont beaucoup de
résonance et d'actualité pour
aujourd'hui alors justement vous avez
parlé de l'Europe dans un an
pratiquement jour pour jour ce sera les
élections européennes le débat est lancé
à gauche sur la possibilité au nom d'une
liste commune entre le PS Europe
Écologie Les Verts la France insoumise
ou encore le Parti communiste mais
parlons plutôt du projet que donc que la
stratégie politique le PS a lancé en
avril la convention Europe à quoi ça
sert justement cette convention et
comment ça se déroule aujourd'hui oui
bah ça sert à effectivement à réfléchir
donc c'est animé par un certain nombre
d'élus socialistes alors ils sont
peut-être pas tous connus mais je vais
citer quelques noms Christophe Clergeot
Nora mes barrek qui sont tous les deux
députés européens chez nous c'est Céline
icman qui était lu à Strasbourg ou
actuellement trois Européens tu penses
que vous connaissez Raphaël Luxman qui
est pas socialisme et qui avait porté
notre liste en 2019 bon il faut
commencer vous avez raison de poser
cette question et je vous en remercie de
cette façon là il faut commencer par les
idées les projets parce que franchement
sinon on entend que liste ensemble liste
séparés bon c'est vachement important
les accords d'appareil les tractations
la tambouille moi je fais de la
politique pour des convictions et des
idées et donc il faut commencer par les
idées nous on est pro européen on peut
être très critique sur les politiques
urbaines moi je suis très critique j'y
ai bossé donc je connais je peux vous
dire je connais très bien les
institutions
de ma vie j'ai plein d'amis une partie
de mon histoire personnelle j'ai voté
non en des moments importants comme 2005
par exemple sur le débat sur le traité
constitutionnel mais je sais
l'importance de l'Europe il est pas
question de sortir de l'Europe de la
défense ou de l'arrêter il est pas
question de sortir de l'OTAN d'ailleurs
on doit être très clair sur le fait
qu'on soutient l'Ukraine et le peuple
ukrainien et que l'agresseur c'est
l'autocrate Poutine on a besoin de plus
d'Europe pas de moins d'Europe dans le
monde avec des grands blocs la Chine les
États-Unis on a besoin de plus d'Europe
et donc bah les alliances à la fin il
faut être clair vous avez mais je le
respecte d'autres formations politiques
qui ont pas du tout notre point de vue
c'est pas des petites différences et
différences de principes de nature pas
de mesure de nature dans ces cas-là à
quoi ça rime de brader nos convictions
pour faire des accords d'appareil allez
faut pas se cacher c'est pour avoir des
places pour avoir des postes sur moi je
mange pas de ce pain là justement la
situation en Europe je l'ai dit le PS a
aujourd'hui trois députés européens qui
siègent donc dans le groupe de
l'Alliance progressiste des socialistes
et démocrates au Parlement européen
c'est le groupe auquel appartient le
Parti socialiste que j'ai pas dit un
groupe qui compte donc 144 députés sur
705 aujourd'hui au Parlement européen un
groupe mené notamment par les Espagnols
du psoé un parti qui est en difficulté
en difficulté actuellement en Espagne le
Premier ministre socialiste espagnol
Pedro Sanchez à dissout le Parlement
juste après les élections municipales la
droite est annoncée gagnante dans les
futurs sondages qui nous gore ce qui
inaugure pas forcément de bonne nouvelle
pour la gauche aux élections européennes
l'année prochaine la gauche aujourd'hui
en Europe elle est au pouvoir dans 6
pays sur 27 est-ce que vous inquiétez au
niveau européen justement que du niveau
de la gauche parce que l'Europe c'est ce
que nous en faisons c'est ce que nous
choisissons là encore faut pas faire de
langue de bois souvent il y a beaucoup
d'abstention les gens pas voter et au
final on se retrouve avec quoi avec une
Europe qui est très majoritairement à
droite vous venez de le dire et ça se
voit dans les politiques alors l'Europe
a évolué quand même faut être nuancé moi
j'ai connu je vous ai dit Bruxelles
entre 2003 et 2008 dans ma vie perso
depuis il y a quand même le Green Deal
il y a quand même des inflexions en
matière notamment environnementale
l'Europe est plus écolo que Emmanuel
Macron ça sans aucun doute et d'ailleurs
la France peut dire merci à l'Europe sur
la partie écologique l'Europe a réussi à
impulser notamment
en matière économique de de
mondialisation en matière d'industrie on
n'est pas du tout suffisamment fort
suffisamment protecteur en matière
sociale c'est une catastrophe il y a
très peu de politique sociale au niveau
européen etc etc et puis les droits
fondamentaux aussi sont battus en brèche
dans certains pays je pense à la Hongrie
par exemple la liberté de la presse les
droits des femmes aussi bon donc il y a
tout un travail et donc on a besoin de
plus de gauche et pour avoir plus de
gauche il faut avoir d'une part plus de
votes donc avec des projets des
convictions et puis aussi des listes qui
permettent une offre politique plus
large parce que je rappelle que c'est
pas du tout le même mode de scrutin que
une élection nationale quand vous avez
une élection nationale présidentielle
avec deux tours ou au deuxième tour il
faut absolument être au deuxième il faut
absolument être deux au second tour bon
bah là effectivement il y a une pression
pour se rassembler au premier mais quand
vous avez un mode de scrutin européen
c'est un tour à la proportionnelle donc
là au contraire les études montrent très
bien les sondages montrent très bien que
si vous avez plusieurs listes vous avez
plus d'élus donc moi qu'est-ce qu'on
veut est-ce qu'on veut plus ou est-ce
qu'on veut moins début de gauche moi je
veux plus de gauche
à l'occasion de la Journée de l'Europe
le 9 mai dernier vous avez publié une
tribune dans Le Journal du dimanche avec
200 personnalités de de gauche pour
justement défendre un Erasmus pour tous
vous en parliez justement il y a
quelques instants alors il y avait
Erasmus maintenant il y a Erasmus plus
vous souhaitez aller encore plus loin
concrètement comment ça se passe parce
que Erasmus c'est une idée magnifique et
ça fonctionne et globalement c'est très
apprécié mais c'est encore assez réservé
pas totalement je veux pas être
caricatural mais
va plutôt des étudiants relativement
aisés pas que mais quand même en
proportion maintenant il y a eu de la
lotion on a ouvert à l'apprentissage
professeur également tout à fait mais
reconnaissons qu'en volume ça reste
faible et quand vous avez une bourse
Erasmus son montant c'est quelque
centaines d'euros et pas négligeable
attention c'est très important mais il
faut forcément des fois un peu c'est pas
suffisant et en fait la différence vous
avez beaucoup de et puis c'est pas
forcément ancré dans les mœurs pour tout
le monde pour beaucoup d'écoles ou
d'universités dans des études
supérieures c'est assez classique de
faire au moins 6 mois dans un pays
étranger de l'Union européenne pour
plein d'autres formations bac + 1 bac +2
ou infrabach c'est pas du tout prévu
c'est pas du tout prévu c'est même pas
envisager espèce d'autocensure donc il
faut faciliter tout ça beaucoup plus
donc Erasmus pour tous c'est une belle
idée je trouve qu'il faut du souffle
aussi pour l'Europe il faut un espoir
parce que si on parle que de traiter de
lys c'est quand même très technocratique
tout ça et le souffle et l'idée ut se
comporte c'est de dire que les nouvelles
générations puissent toutes faire quel
que soit leur niveau d'études nourri
loger blanchi au moins 6 mois dans un
autre pays l'Union européenne voilà et
ça ce serait une belle idée pourquoi
parce qu'évidemment en termes
d'éducation et puis de d'édification
personnelle bien sûr parce qu'on apprend
énormément quand on se retrouve dans une
autre culture et aussi en termes de
compréhension de l'autre parce que
reconnaissons que l'Europe si je vous
demande enfin land ou en Croatie à
Croatie c'est un peu particulier mais
vous voyez ce que je veux dire à chaque
fois
je dis la Croatie parce que en fait
c'est pas l'Union européenne au sens
strict vous avez vous pouvez aller par
exemple en Norvège qui est pas dans
l'Union européenne voilà bon mais en
fait vous vous constatez que à chaque
fois il y a des différences culturelles
importantes à vrai dire en France si
vous prenez l'île ou Marseille il y a
des différences culturelles importantes
aussi et donc ce qui est intéressant
c'est de pouvoir en ayant une vision
large de l'Europe l'Ukraine n'est pas
dans l'Union européenne mais moi je
trouve qu'elle est à l'instant pour
l'instant mais aller faire des Erasmus
pas aujourd'hui évidemment mais un jour
l'idée que demain on puisse ne se
connaitre et mieux se comprendre je
pense que ce serait formidable donc
voilà une utopie que l'on essaye de
porter cette idée c'est aussi de donc
les races muscles pour pour tous c'est
on va dire d'intégrer un peu tout le
monde à ce projet européen aujourd'hui
jeunesse vous en avez et que ça devienne
banal comme l'air qu'on respire vous
avez dit aujourd'hui que l'Europe était
perçue pour comme parfois contraignant
il y a une forme de décalage entre les
citoyens l'Union européenne qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire aussi pour pour
rapprocher tout ce monde l'Europe est
souvent vu comme un problème alors que
c'est fondamentalement une solution
pourquoi parce que tous les grands
sujets de ce siècle le réchauffement
climatique c'est pas en France c'est le
monde entier on va dire on sera plus
efficace l'immigration les questions
migratoires qui vont pas s'arrêter
notamment à cause du réchauffement
climatique c'est pas un sujet national
mais vous pouvez aller très loin comme
ça la régulation de la finance et
l'ultra finance elle est mondialisée
la question du numérique les Gafa le
rapport géopolitique à la Russie à la
Chine aux Etats-Unis au bloc africain
qui se développe phénoménalement etc etc
donc on a besoin d'être à l'échelle des
sujets le problème c'est que quand vous
montez l'échelle vous perdez en
proximité et donc pour beaucoup de gens
ben l'Europe au niveau local d'abord il
y a pas Monsieur Madame Europe au coin
de la rue dans le marché le dimanche et
on voit par contre les normes les
contraintes et donc aux yeux voilà
qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent nous embêter
pour pas dire
pas de langue de bois les élus quand il
y a ça va bien en dit c'est grâce à nous
puis quand ça va pas on dit c'est la
faute de Bruxelles bon je rappelle que
l'Europe c'est des décisions la plupart
du temps faites avec les États membres
par les États membres donc c'est à dire
par nous en réalité bref tout ça pour
dire qu'on a besoin de plus de proximité
donc pour moi il faut remettre plus de
démocratie plus d'associations directes
plus de compréhension culturelles tous
les enjeux culturels qui créent un
affectueux sociétatif si vous voulez par
exemple Rouen et candidate pour être
capital européenne de la culture 2028 en
2028 mais ça c'est très important parce
que c'est évidemment important pour
Rouen pour la vallée de Seine c'est
important aussi pour le lien avec
l'Europe voilà et puis des projets
concrets vous voyez
Erasmus c'est un projet concret c'est
une utopie un espoir un souffle mais
c'est aussi un projet concret de la même
façon carbus qui est un projet européen
c'est un projet concret et c'est ça qui
marche alors récemment Emmanuel Macron
lors du discours de Bratislava a
souhaité promouvoir l'élargissement de
l'UE donc on parle de six pays
potentiels l'Albanie la Serbie le Kosovo
la Macédoine du Nord la Moldavie et puis
l'Ukraine dont on parlait sur les 10
dernières années la question de
l'élargissement de l'UE c'était un peu
un tabou on était plutôt sur la tendance
inverse avec le brexit aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous vous soutenez cette
tendance ce que ça peut être une bonne
chose ou pas
oui sur le principe en fait quand on
regarde à chaque élargissement
chaque extension l'Union européenne qui
a commencé à 6 avec les pays fondateurs
c'était à peu près à chaque fois pas
toujours mais quasi à chaque fois motivé
par des raisons
géopolitiques fondamentales la
révolution des œillets au Portugal et le
Portugal ensuite qui intègre la Grèce le
régime des colonels etc vous voyez ce
que je veux dire donc à chaque fois
quasi à chaque fois vous avez un lien
c'est le sens de l'histoire si vous
voulez et l'Ukraine géographiquement est
en Europe on est à l'ouest de l'Oural on
est en Europe et et fondamentalement
d'ailleurs on accueille beaucoup de
réfugiés Ukrainiens ici à Rouen on
partage beaucoup de choses d'ailleurs
cette année les fêtes Jeanne d'Arc était
sous le parrainage enfin le marrainage
des femmes combattantes ukrainiennes et
voilà pour l'anecdote dans l'équipe des
tireurs ou tireuse d'élite de l'armée
ukrainienne il y a une femme Tyrus
d'élite donc sniper qui dans le surnom
dans l'armée ukrainienne et Jeanne d'Arc
donc bien sûr qu'il y a des liens très
forts après l'expérience des
intégrations précédentes les anciens
pays de l'ex bloque soviétique l'Apple
que je dise pas de bêtises la Slovaquie
etc à Slovénie voilà tous ces pays quand
ils sont entrés pareils c'était le sens
de l'histoire mais ça peut pas se faire
en claquant des doigts attention parce
qu'il y a une question d'intégration et
d'harmonisation et c'est comme une
famille plus on est nombreux plus c'est
compliqué de s'entendre a priori donc
attention à bien préserver nos valeurs
fondamentales en particulier les droits
humains parce qu'on le voit sur des
sujets fondamentaux la liberté le droit
à l'intégrité et au respect de son corps
notamment pour les femmes je pense à
l'avortement la liberté de la presse la
démocratie au sens large la France
défend aussi la laïcité qui n'est pas
une conception partagée partout en
Europe
toutes ces toutes ces valeurs je pense
sont des valeurs qui qui peuvent être
remises en cause y compris très
gravement donc il faut faire très
attention l'Europe ça ne peut pas être
qu'un marché sous prétexte d'intégrer on
va faire un marché intérieur bien sûr
que c'est une puissance la puissance
économique mais l'Europe c'est une
communauté de destins et de valeur alors
nous allons passer maintenant la
deuxième partie de l'hebdopolitique
[Musique]
toujours avec Nicolas Maillard Rossignol
premier secrétaire délégué du Parti
socialiste et mère de Rouen depuis
mercredi l'Armada est de retour dans la
ville un large rassemblement de grands
voiliers qui est organisé donc tous les
quatre à six ans depuis 1989 c'est un
événement qui a su s'imposer dans le
cœur des roisés c'est culte c'est
l'événement ne pas rater c'est la fête
c'est la fête c'est la fête c'est une
fête extraordinaire franchement il y a
pas mieux en France et je dis pas ça
pour vendre Rouen c'est le plus grand si
ce n'est oui le plus grand rassemblement
de voiliers en France et l'un des plus
grands au monde et vous avez parmi les
plus beaux et les plus grands voiliers
du monde à 1h30 de Paris dans un endroit
magnifique qui est Rouen qui est
l'agglomération à l'aise avec plein de
choses à faire autour il y a tellement à
voir dans notre région en Normandie
enfin c'est vraiment extraordinaire 6
millions de visiteurs donc attendu cette
année ça crée des retombées économiques
et touristiques intéressantes pour la
ville pour l'agglomération très
difficile à quantifier à l'euro près
mais
oui pour deux raisons la première c'est
la raison d'évidence c'est que c'est
l'enjeu de ce siècle la protection de
notre environnement et que l'Armada s'y
prête parfaitement puisque le cœur de
l'Armada sont les bateaux et la scène
donc les fleuves les océans avec
l'Institut mondial des océans meilleur
compréhension du fleuve vous savez la
scène a été excusez-moi mais violée
depuis l'après-guerre pour des raisons
qui à l'époque je ne juge pas été
compréhensive fallait reconstruire la
France on a mis des usines les usines
elles polluent la scène elle a été
contaminée pendant très longtemps ça va
mieux mais ça reste parce que vous avez
des polluants qui restent longtemps dans
les bouts de dragage par exemple de la
scène pendant très longtemps la plupart
des poissons de la Seine était
hermaphrodite c'est-à-dire que changer
de sexe dans leur vie pourquoi parce que
ils mangeaient des perturbateurs en
ocriniens qui étaient des polluants
qu'on trouve dans les bouts de la Seine
dans le fond de la Seine etc etc je veux
pas faire peur mais c'est une réalité et
puis il y a les évolutions à venir le
réchauffement climatique et l'élévation
du niveau de l'eau
dans la scène mais il y a aussi des
dangers parce que avec d'échauffement
climatique le niveau de l'eau va monter
donc des zones qui n'étaient pas
inondables vont le devenir à horizon
2050 2100 il faut dire la vérité donc
comment est-ce qu'on appréhende tout ça
donc l'enjeu écologique il est majeur
puis à la question des plastiques 0
plastique la question de la protection
de la biodiversité etc ça c'est la
première raison et puis il y a une
seconde raison qui est liée à la
première c'est je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure on est candidat pour être
capital européenne de la culture en 2028
il y avait 9 candidatures en France au
départ il en reste plus que 4 donc on a
déjà passé avec succès brio comme
première
des villes comme Nice Bastia Reims
Amiens Saint-Denis n'ont pas été retenu
malheureusement pour elle et il reste
clairement Ferrand Bourges Montpellier
et Rouen alors c'est pas que Rouen c'est
Rouen vallée de scène normande de
Giverny jusqu'au Havre on est tous
rassemblés et le lien c'est notre lieu
c'est la scène et donc l'Armada
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de mieux comme écrin
pour montrer notre candidature donc vous
allez voir partout bah des affiches des
panneaux des explications sur notre
projet de capital européenne de la
culture qui met la suite ça pourrait
être la prochaine édition de
et donc c'est un enjeu majeur qui nous
concerne pas que les Normands puisqu'on
travaille avec les franciliens et
l'entente de l'axe scène dont vous
parlez elle rassemble aussi les élus
locaux sur le bord de Seine en région
Île-de-France en amont en fait de
Giverny en remontant vers Paris jusqu'à
Paris avec Anne Hidalgo effectivement
avec Patrick Ollier pour le Grand Paris
et puis avec Édouard Philippe pour Le
Havre on s'entend très bien on n'est pas
du même bord politique mais on s'entend
très bien vraiment c'est là encore c'est
sans langue de bois il y a une vraie
communauté de point de vue pour cet
enjeu sur quoi ben les enjeux
économiques je viens d'en parler
l'énergie parce que l'historiquement
cette vallée de scène elle est très
carbonée il faut la décarbonée mais en
même temps on veut créer de l'emploi de
l'industrie de l'activité économique
donc c'est du photovoltaïque c'est on a
créé une société commune avec des
millions d'euros dedans pour capitaliser
pour investir ça peut être de la
biomasse ça peut être de l'hydrogène on
a des projets magnifiques l'éolien marin
du côté du Havre etc etc la logistique
pour utiliser mieux le fleuve
mieux le train et moins les camions
parce qu'aujourd'hui 84 85 % des
marchandises en France et sur l'axe
scène à repas les trois ports de paris
en live 85 % passent par camion c'est
nul si vous allez à Hambourg ou en verre
c'est pas du tout le même chiffre et
pourtant ils sont meilleurs que nous
économiquement donc on va pouvoir faire
mieux et puis la culture mais j'en ai
déjà parlé alors justement l'axe scène
vous parliez du transport donc
autoroutier l'axe scène représente déjà
50% du frais de fluvial français
c'est assez faible mais ça représente
50% donc c'est 50% de pas grand chose le
transport maritime doit-il se développer
selon vous peut-il constituer une
alternative justement à ce transport
routier dont nous vous parlez transport
fluvial le transport maritime est déjà
très développé puisque pour des raisons
liées à la mondialisation vous
connaissez les grands portent conteneurs
80% je crois quelque chose comme ça des
marchandises sont transportés dans le
monde par bateau voie maritime mais une
fois que vous arrivez au Havre
et que vous voulez arriver à Paris c'est
plus compliqué mais là le transport
maritime au fluvial sur 100 marchandises
d'Aro pas un port ou export 85 par
camion 10% par fleuve 5% par le train
c'est nul et encore une fois les
meilleurs ports d'Europe ils sont dans
le nord de l'Europe auteur dame en verre
en bourse la part train fleuve dans ces
ports là elle est beaucoup plus forte
donc ils sont meilleurs plans économique
et meilleur en plan écologique donc on
doit pouvoir faire mieux et le mot clé
c'est décarbonation ça veut dire quoi
mettre plus de barge si possible débarge
électrique ou à hydrogène ça veut dire
faciliter les conditions économiques
d'utilisation du fleuve ça veut dire
miser sur le ferroviaire le train le
train le train aujourd'hui on n'a pas
assez de ligne on a des lignes qui sont
développées pour le frais de ferroviaire
c'est-à-dire que Gisors par exemple bon
c'est pas toujours simple vous avez vu
les déclarations madame Pécresse
ce transport fluvial vous souhaitez
également donc développer l'axe de la
scène du Havre à Paris notamment avec le
projet donc de la ligne nouvelle Paris
Normandie c'est une promesse qui a été
faite il y a quelques années déjà
maintenant par Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007
et qui traîne en longueur aujourd'hui
donc l'aboutissement du projet il est
prévu donc pour 2040 mais donc vous
venez de l'évoquer la présente l'air de
la région de France Valérie si oppose
elle reproche donc à l'état de dépenser
près de 11 milliards d'euros pour cette
cette ligne alors que la région
Île-de-France souffre déjà d'un
sous-investissement donc en termes de
transport de plus le projet donc
consommerait 280 hectares de terre
agricoles dans le département des
Yvelines est-ce que vous comprenez un
petit peu cette position de Valérie
Pécresse ou pas du tout je pense qu'il y
a des raisons qui sont un peu
conjoncturelles et des élections bientôt
sénatoriales il y a des négociations en
cours entre la Région Île-de-France et
l'État sur ce qu'on appelle les contrats
de plan
en gros les investissements et combien
l'État est prêt à mettre pour aider la
région de France je pense qu'il y a un
peu un jeu de de rapport de force dans
cette période mais si on regarde avec
une vision large en essayant de prendre
un peu de hauteur de vue
aujourd'hui je pense qu'en Île-de-France
les franciliens et Madame Pécresse
également
n'aime pas beaucoup voir autant de
camions se déverser sur les routes
d'Île-de-France et tous ces camions vous
en avez beaucoup qui viennent de l'axe
scène parce qu'il y a des
usines parce qu'il y a de
l'import-export parce qu'il y a des
céréales parce que il y a du
pétrole parce que etc etc donc faut
changer ça faut changer ça et encore une
fois c'est pas un enjeu anti-économique
les meilleurs ports d'Europe du Nord
d'Europe ils sont en Europe du Nord ils
sont meilleurs au niveau économique et
écologique et c'est mieux pour tout le
monde donc en fait on a un intérêt
commun et c'est à l'état de porter cela
et moi je salue il y a beaucoup d'élus
franciliens dans les Yvelines par
exemple qui soutiennent le projet parce
qu'ils ont compris alors c'est vrai que
ça peut générer des nuisances y compris
chez nous et vous savez en Normandie on
a aussi des nuisances on a des
raffineries pour du pétrole qui est
consommé en Île-de-France bon
c'est un enjeu de solidarité aussi mais
je pense que c'est gagnant-gagnant et
globalement d'ailleurs en France on a
besoin de plus de train on a besoin de
plus de ferroviaire on a trop diminué le
ferroviaire c'est pas une histoire de
TGV en l'occurrence puisque Rouen Paris
c'est 120 km c'est pas besoin d'être à
300 km/h mais par contre on a besoin de
plus de scions oui moi hier je prenais
le train pour revenir de Paris il y a eu
un ballast mis de façon intentionnelle
d'ailleurs sur la voie le train devant
il s'est retrouvé bloqué bon il y avait
pas assez de Sion on était bloqué aussi
et on a pris une demi-heure 40 minutes
de retard et c'est malheureusement trop
fréquent régulier et ceux qui prennent
le train régulièrement ils le savent
très bien et tout ça est congestionné
donc il faut arriver à changer ça on a
besoin de plus de trains pour ça il faut
y aller tous ensemble faut pousser le
projet ensemble merci beaucoup Nicolas
Mayer Rossignol d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous je m'appelle donc que vous
êtes le premier secrétaire délégué du
Parti socialiste émerge de Rouen c'était
le dernier numéro de l'hebdopolitique de
la saison merci de nous avoir suivi
cette année je vous souhaite un très bel
été sur sensation
politique